hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video leute
ich hoffe natürlich euch geht es gut und
die meisten fragen wahrscheinlich gerade
was ist bei dir schon wieder passiert
warum sieht es wieder anders aus
vielleicht manchmal ein separates video
zu dem ganzen thema auf jeden fall ist
bei mir grad eine menge los vieles
verändert sich wahrscheinlich und es ist
auch alles ein bisschen ungewohnt
natürlich ich weiß nicht ob ich das hier
hochladen ich wollte den hauptkanal
eigentlich nicht mehr für so was nutzen
checkt auf jeden fall dafür am liebsten
einen zweiten oder neuen kanal ab da
gibt es dann vielleicht von video oder
zu dass ein bisschen ausführlicher
thematisiert wird erster linie in der
video beschreibung wir lassen uns von
dem ganzen aber nicht beeinflussen heute
gibt es natürlich ein neues video ich
freundlich megas tut mir auch leid das
die letzten tage wieder nichts kam
eigentlich soll ja mal sonntag hier auf
jeden fall das hofft video kommen und
dann donnerstags das hat sich jetzt ein
bisschen verschoben es geht heute um
produkte die ich auf tik tok gesehen
habe und dann wiederum auf amazon
gestellt habt also sozusagen ich weiß ja
jeder von euch diesen trend kennt tik
tok made me by bis wirklich super
verrückte produkte die auf der einen
seite sehr hilfreich sind auf der
anderen seite auch vielleicht nicht
werden wir herausfinden das ganze hab
ich schon bei anderen youtube angesehen
wie zum beispiel rock oder so auch mega
cool ich habe versucht ein paar andere
produkte zu finden habe ich auch auf
jeden fall geschafft also checkt auch
super gerne mal seine videos zu dem
thema ab und wir starten jetzt direkt
mit dem ersten und das ist folgendes
[Musik]
ach so es ging eigentlich nur das erste
produkt es ist ja klar dass ich das
bestellen muss oder wer wenn nicht ich
ja wir haben hier einfach ein xxl
airport ich weiß nicht ob da einer drin
ist oder zwei habe ich bestellt ich weiß
nicht mehr wie teures war alle produkte
sind natürlich auch wie immer in der
video beschreibung verlinkt und mir
macht das jetzt mal auf wir stets auch
schon scheint headset speaker also ich
denke mal es ist ein riesiger airport
als music box oder das ist eigentlich
auch das worauf ich mich am meisten
gefreut habe ist ja blöd dass ich das
vielleicht direkt am anfang zeigen aber
egal
ok china das ist wirklich krass oh mein
gott alter von der besteigung bei doch
ach so ja das ist einfach eine bluetooth
vor
wenn man sieht dass genial aus hallo
hallo hallo hallo könnte man auch als
telefon benutzen was läuft was läuft was
läuft sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein
telefon aus der zukunft wir machen den
mal auch gemeint ist direkt an
doch jetzt mal die musik checken g2
heißt das dingen keine ahnung warum ich
bin schon verbunden dann hören wir mal
ein bisschen was flippiges
ok ich sehe gerade man kann hier auch
per usb kabel verbinden man kann lauter
leiser machen die lieder wechseln
eine sogar eine mini sd karte kann man
hier reinstecken muss ich sagen an sich
der sound war jetzt nicht überragend
habe ich auch nicht erwartet trotzdem
geniales dingen also das stelle ich mir
auf jeden fall ins regal einige sachen
palo sich auch immer auf meinem insta
bereich das ehrlicherweise in letzter
zeit nicht mehr so durchgezogen habe tut
mir ein bisschen leid kriegen wir wieder
hin den behalte ich aber auf jeden fall
als 10.000 likes für dieses ding bedankt
und dann kommen wir auch direkt zum
nächsten produkt also ich weiß nicht was
mit dieser frau los ist auf jeden fall
wirklich auf mich als hätte sie
irgendwelche drogen genommen diese diese
reaction dame da ich wusste auch nicht
dass man auch tik tok heutzutage auch
reagiert aber ist anscheinend so und ich
mal ein bisschen vor ja das ist los mit
dieser frau kam mir das irgendwann sagen
[Musik]
also das ist mega neuestes produkt ist
halt so ein apfel schneider und dann ist
der apfel kann man den direkten ich habe
das mal bestellt und wir schauen mal
optisch lassen überzeugt
was steht da drauf apple peter kaiser
ach so man kann damit auch glaube ich
kartoffeln schälen
weil das wäre was für mama muss ich
immer zeigen reicht also nicht das wird
er doch sie macht schon mal die
kartoffeln ihr also wenn das wirklich so
einwandfrei funktioniert habe ich da
auch direkt eine verwendung für ja sagt
kommt irgendwo aus united kingdom also
es ist gar nicht mal so klein ich hatte
es mir eigentlich sogar hat glaube ich
20 euro kostet wenn du den vernünftigen
apfel schneiden willst dann braucht man
vielleicht auch so was so jetzt will ich
aber jetzt muss ich das erstmal hier
installieren
wir machen mal ab ich sehe schon kommen
gleich es wegen meiner hand ab oder so
beschreibung bitte kannst du hier bei
mir ich habe jetzt gerade mal ein
kleines tutorial angeguckt dazu online
man kann du kannst ja auch ist man muss
das so ein bisschen einstellen erst mal
hier und mit dem hebel kann man das
dingen fest machen dann können wir das
hier lösen und dass wir so ein bisschen
nach hinten ziehen sagt dann kann man
das hier ein bisschen einstellen das
ziehen wir hier ein bisschen nach hinten
und stecken
den apfel drauf bis zum anschlag ja wohl
hier und im optimalen fall müsste das
jetzt funktionieren
so hat sie doch nicht schlecht auto
bekommt man hier ja wolle
regen eis wirklich das macht spaß das
ist auch so ein bisschen satisfied oder
zack und da ist der apfel geschält und
jetzt kann ich denn ich dachte ich kann
jetzt auseinander ziehen dass mir ich
glaube ich könnte das noch ein bisschen
fest sei ein schöner ja erstmal hier als
ein apfel
früher habe ich den immer ohne schale
gegessen berufliche erfüllung euro an
apple a day keeps the doctor away
ich stelle das jetzt mal ein bisschen
ein bisschen fester ein paar leute jetzt
hab ich's gecheckt wir brauchen hier
vorne noch dieses dinge hier und jetzt
passiert hoffentlich folgendes dass der
dann so ein bisschen watte wir versuchen
es einfach mal
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob sie klappt
aber es könnte schon
abdo vorsicht ja das sollte das lecker
na ja auf jeden fall ist das teil nicht
schlecht um äpfel zu stehlen was ich
jetzt gerade hier gemacht haben die
nächstes produkt wir machen weiter
[Musik]
entschuldigung das liegt an den bäumen
hoffe ich zumindest auch wenn ich im
corona krisengebiet mich gerade aufhalte
ich habe da ja vielleicht mitbekommen
leute wir haben hier den einzig wahren
watermelon warum kommt eigentlich alles
auf jeder verpackung die ich bestelle
ist in irgendwelche chinesischen zeichen
drauf das weiß nicht warum das so ist
ist also auf jeden fall kann man mit
diesen dingen ganz easy eine
wassermelone schneiden und sich nicht
komplett die finger dreckig machen und
ob das wirklich funktioniert check name
aus aus okay ja also sieht auf jeden
fall genauso aus wie in diesem video
ich glaube dass dinge hat zehn euro
gekostet bei amazon aber wenn das
wirklich funktioniert ist es mir das
auch wäre okay jetzt bauen wir eine
wassermelone die habe ich natürlich auch
eingekauft da vorne müsste die ligen ist
eine mini wassermelone sogar bio
warenangebot 199 okay dann brauchen wir
mal durchschneiden
ach so vielleicht ist das auch ein
bisschen dumm dass ich so eine kleine
wassermelone genommen habt eine große
wäre vielleicht besser gewesen die wahl
deutlich besser gewesen egal kann man
jetzt nicht ändern
wir müssen nur sehen ob es funktionieren
kann und deswegen nehme ich das stück
beiseite setzt den hier an drückt den
drauf
ich bin aber auch einen vollidioten ich
habe es natürlich mal wieder komplett
falsch gemacht alter ja ich will immer
alles zu überhastet dann machen wir
müssen das hier leider noch abschreiben
auf der einen seite und auf der anderen
seite das gleiche und jetzt funktioniert
es auch jetzt muss man nämlich einfach
das ding hier ansetzen
darum noch dran hätte auch schiefgehen
können
dann kann sich das hier einfach so ganz
entspannt heißt funktioniert doch man
ist ganz entspannt hier so durchfahren
auch so ein bisschen set ist fallen also
bei einer großen wassermelone
funktioniert das sicherlich noch mal
besser aber ich würde nicht sagen dass
es hier nicht funktioniert es
funktioniert einwandfrei leute wie geil
alter und jetzt haben wir ganz viele
fonds haben millionen stücke die hier
alles zusammen
ich muss erst mal aufräumen bevor ich
weitermache aber dieses gadget kann ich
euch auf jeden fall empfehlen brutal
vielleicht kennt man das auch also ich
kannte das jetzt nicht deswegen hab ich
bestellt und mein stuhl
das hat gerade echt ein bisschen ins
auge gehen können und einen daumen wir
machen weiter mit dem nächsten produkt
und das ist folgendes okay das nächste
produkt
ich weiß nicht ob das also es ist schon
cool an sich weil wir können es nicht
also ich glaube das ist so eine art
feuerzeug
wir schauen uns erst mal das video eine
entschuldigung
[Musik]
natürlich auch wer hätte es gedacht made
in china steht hinten drauf wenn ich
jetzt auf mache kommen wir
wahrscheinlich schon wir die
chinesischen buchstaben entgegen was ich
gerade sagen wollte wer kennt es nicht
man hat zu hause ganz viele fahrzeuge
weil dieses jahr leer gehen und man die
dann halt hat zum teil auch wieder neu
befüllen kann macht man allerdings
meistens nicht und das hier ist
anscheinend ein gerät also ich hoffe ich
habe das jetzt richtig verstanden was
sozusagen was sozusagen halt kerzen
anzünden kann allerdings mit strom also
ich weiß es nicht genau wie es
funktioniert ich denke mal mit ja was
ist das da oben er halt wie so eine art
zigarettenanzünder im auto kann man sich
das glaube ich vorstellen hier dann
sowie power bank auf power bank
angelehnt bisschen stufen zu wie viel
prozent ist noch aufgeladen ist und hier
steht drauf usb-kabel in zeiten mit
runter guck mal kannst du ganz einfach
mit seinem mini usb kabel aufladen sagt
also ich habe sowas wirklich noch nie
gesehen und ich werde es meinen eltern
schenken die werden sich unfassbar
darüber freuen weil die da immer viele
kerzen anzünden unten aber trotzdem muss
ich das jetzt einmal abschätzen ob das
auch wirklich funktioniert kommen die
kerze ist wieder da wollen wir mal raus
das ist das macht irgendwie so ganz
hohen ton im ohr
ich weiß nicht das sagt aber schon
brennt die kerze
also ich frag mich auch wieso ich das
vorher nicht hatte oder wieso ich nicht
kannte
ich frage mich sowieso bei diesen ganzen
sachen warum ich die bis jetzt nicht
kannte also ich bin jetzt aber überlegen
ein paar habe ich sogar noch sagte jetzt
hier im video zeigen dann noch mehrere
parks machen ich würde eigentlich sagen
wenn ihr sagt alex noch mehrere parks
dazu lasst doch nach oben da dann kommt
er auf jeden fall noch das eine oder
andere jetzt riecht ein bisschen nach
auch als hätte ich viel rauch kommt da
abonniert auf jeden fall alle den kanal
würde ich mich sehr darüber freuen
abonniert auf meinen zweiten kanal alex
v wo es dann auch dieses spezielle video
geben wird
das ist ein bisschen komisch ist mit der
kerze man hat die ausgepustet aber sie
ist nicht richtig aus ich glaube das ist
diese kerze nicht gewohnt diese danke
fürs zuschauen und wir sehen uns in
wenigen tagen hier wieder oder auf
alexander hleb ziemlich jeden tag video